people believe that they know their
where
their area where they live and they
actually don't that much not as much
uh they know their street they but they
don't really understand the patterns
enough
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
to 20 minute leaders i'm excited about
this episode for a variety of reasons
but one of them is because we all hate
parking
meet ayal amir the ceo and founder of
park nav a growing startup that offers
ai technology to find parking in real
time
[Applause]
welcome to 20 minute leaders all the way
from munich right now thank you so much
for joining me thank you mikhail
first of all thank you not for the
podcast but but for helping or trying to
solve one of the most important problems
in our world it's something that
frustrates us on a day-to-day basis
something that frustrates me especially
living in tel aviv
parking a an unsolved crisis since 100
years ago when cars were first
hit on the road
and so i'm excited to hear about you
both your personal journey with a phd
from stanford in computer science and
then also as an adjunct associate
professor in illinois
and working in in remarkable positions
across some of the some of the top tech
companies until you're now the ceo for
the last few years of park nav so ayal
welcome to the show thank you
take me back you know seven years ago uh
because i really want to spend the
majority of the time talking about
parking what made you start park nav
parking
uh i was uh a while ago i had the chance
to be in in tel aviv while i was still
in a tenure track at uh
university of illinois in urbana and i
was uh there uh for i've been doing ai
for at the time like 15 years
and
i
couldn't find parking of course my dad
won't come to my place and uh
it's uh in i was living in tel aviv
right next to the city hall and it's a
terrible
you know
terrible place uh to find parking in uh
you know you you come back uh at like 7
p.m you will spend 30 minutes looking
for parking if you come at nine you just
forget it you know for the next two
hours just sit in the coffee place
somewhere
and wait for somebody to to leave and
then go park it one in the morning and
uh i've been doing ai for all that time
i was thinking you know there must be
some
something that i could do
i tried actually to do with a couple of
partners tried to do some sort of a
market making mechanisms where people
would leave and then they will sell you
they sell to you the information that
they're leaving
but uh we found out that uh long before
uh somebody found out that they you know
tried this idea
and uh people want to buy the
information but not enough people want
to sell the information
so
we uh you know i looked at other
approaches a lot of people back then
told me uh you know sensors will conquer
the world everywhere will be with
sensors forget about you know don't
worry about it sensors will solve the
problem
but you know i by that time i was living
in chicago and it was like
what's what's going on i mean i i cannot
find parking it's ridiculous let's find
you know let's solve the problem so uh
started walking the streets with a
clipboard
you know
well in this time there is a there is
like two spots and
the other time there is like four spots
and other times there are zero spots and
yeah and and started putting it into uh
some models and uh there was some
pattern so so what i mean what i'm
hearing from you is that uh you know if
we're looking at if we're considering
sensors as a solution we're looking at
dedicated parking spots and
understanding that in this exact
location there's a parking space and you
were looking at it from one level higher
and saying well let's look at the macro
trend on a street level
or on a location level and say okay can
we make a prediction on how many spots
there will be in a given area given that
i don't actually care if it's here or
here as long as it's close by and it's
also you know it's a you know it's a
common thing that that
people say i think reid hoffman said it
many people say that you you have to
really focus on the end user's problem
and i was the end user
there are no sensors in the streets and
you know and even if i put
i was you know don't tell anyone but i i
put like a camera outside my my uh my
window and you know
filmed the street
and then you know my neighbor complained
that i'm videotaping people and all of
that and
you know and but it solves the problem
for only one street and i needed to then
convince all of those other homeowners
to have a solution you know and and i
needed to find parking next to a coffee
place randomly like just up north in the
city
you know that's a big
a big investment not to mention a big
problem and i needed to solve the
problem now so it's very pragmatic kind
of uh
share with me this journey the you know
years of journey of of trying to solve
this problem for and and i'll just skip
for a second to the end to give context
at least according to the most updated
version i saw uh running in more than a
thousand cities with more than five and
a half billion parking slots um
fulfilled almost the number of people in
in the world so amazing amazing really
but
this it didn't happen overnight it
happened over several years what was the
journey like for you
well you know uh there are many many
stories right i think many founders
would tell similar stories uh
i i'm
i'll tell just you know one example is
um
yeah you know i ran out of money i had
uh you know i burned a hole in my credit
card and it's uh it's kind of uh you
feel a little bit weird you know hey you
know i i used to be a tenured professor
in a top five university it's like what
what is this
and uh you know at any day i could maybe
hopefully can find a job
how can i be without money and so
you know in retrospect i'll tell you i i
just really did not know how to do my
accounting well i should have taken
accounting 101
you know it's really one of the best
advice to to all new entrepreneurs take
accounting
very important
we actually have a class at stanford
where you did your phd by adam nash who
was vice president of dropbox and ceo of
wealth of wealthfront and he it's his
class for for engineers and
entrepreneurs it's sort of accounting
101 or how to understand money because
he said you know you're all very smart
but you have no idea how to count your
money and how to do anything with it so
i can see that you're very much in
agreement with him yes and you know i
i'm a mathematician in my training and
you know it's like
what do you mean it's just mathematics
right
it's a little bit more
yes right a lot of nuances so what
happened so so you're burning through
the first of all why you know why didn't
it work in the beginning what what did
you what did you find
that didn't work in the journey well you
know the the the the easiest the
observation is that you know i built the
company together with my co-founder
segay at the time it was uh
i i did uh you know i assumed it would
be like in the 90s the end of the 90s
some of my friends created google some
of my other friends uh created other
companies it's like yeah you know just
build it and then it happens right
no so uh that was not the case
so
uh the technology worked i you know it
was like whoa i couldn't believe it it
actually works but um but yeah but the
business model took me a long time
uh yeah in retrospect we just needed
very different people you know i didn't
have experience in building startups
none of us did
and
i really underestimated how much it it
matters
yeah
incredible incredible and and obviously
you're referring you know your friend
you know you did your phd from 95 to
2002 and there's some overlap with some
very interesting people
who've built some of the most important
companies and search and algorithms in
the world
but
what where are we at today so if you're
looking at you know not even park now
but if we're going 30 000 feet in the
air and we're looking at parking
solutions
in conjunction with ai and mathematics
how do these two things converge into a
solution that is viable both in terms of
unit economics but also in terms of
consumer behavior so
the unit economics is really cool uh
meaning
that people have value to finding
parking
and finding it quickly uh but different
people have different value right so if
i'm going to a business meeting
then my value is just parking the
closest the most convenient
and just the fastest and it doesn't
matter so much how much it costs and and
when i go to uh meet some friends uh for
for coffee then it does matter and i
will park maybe a few blocks away
and save the money and just walk so
so there is value and the the problem is
really well for there are two problems
one is how to deliver the value
to the end user and then how to
uh capture the value so yeah when you so
so delivering the value
uh the the natural ways is through
companies that already approach the end
user with with a complete solution like
car manufacturers they have a complete
solution you know or you know google
they have a complete solution so these
or or pango let's say a mobile payment
app
they have a complete solution
that the user already uses why not just
add the information to that solution
so that's you know that sounds great
from from how to deliver it to the end
user but how to capture that was the
capturing that's right and why would the
those companies give you that value you
know that
so
turns out uh depending on the market
there are different ways of providing
value to those companies so
the the easiest and that we've had the
um
forgive me for a little bit of uh kind
of like details in inside the company
but uh we did have a good success in the
last year uh with providing the
information to companies like pango so
companies that provide uh uh data to
uh so provide mobile payment solutions
to to end users and so for example pango
in uh poland
uh which was founded by similar uh uh
people who came out of pango israel uh
they have a mobile app before payment of
parking for parking and we provide them
with information
now i'm not gonna go into all the unit
economics specifically for that deal but
in general the principle is that every
time that somebody pays for parking we
get a little bit of value from that uh
payment
so and it makes sense because we improve
the experience of the end user we make
them more sticky in your app we make
them more likely to use your app for
many other services
exactly the one has a distribution
channel and one has an additional value
that you're creating on top of it that
makes perfect sense yeah and and the
same goes with car manufacturers by the
way car manufacturers were the earliest
adapters our first first first customer
was bmw uh and they uh really were
fantastic
of course fantastic partners they they
really care about the
the the
how do you say
the
uh the precision of things the quality
and so it really matched with our values
and and they helped us a lot in refining
what how we think about the product
um and they also again they have a way
of capturing the value they have a way
of of uh
using the value that you provide to
capture more value on their side and
they provide an end user with a
navigation unit that costs more
but is worth more for the end user and
the use and user pays for it so again
exactly and so obviously you know
looking looking now at
more than a thousand cities that's great
i'm guessing that's also a part of the
technology but then you're looking at
the five and a half billion parking
slots fulfilled which is the
distribution so the model is obviously
you know there's there's validation for
it right
going back to the technology identifying
these five and a half billion slots i'm
very very curious about that how does
that work so i mean that example that i
give at the beginning with uh this guy
walking with a clipboard
uh
it's a scale up from that so it sounds
it sounds like this is ridiculous but uh
it is i think
we there are a couple of observations
that i noticed along the way that still
to this day people don't believe me are
true
uh i'm ready
one is um that there is much more
order in the world of parking
it's much more predictable than you
think
and the second thing is people believe
that they know their where
their area where they live and they
actually don't that much not as much
uh they know their street they but they
don't really understand the patterns
enough in the neighboring streets ah
so
okay uh
uh we can run some experiments but uh
you'll see you'll see we did run
external i'm already thinking back to my
own to my own neighborhood and figuring
out how many streets do i actually know
and what the parking habits are and i'm
pretty limited to my corner and if that
doesn't then i go to the parking lot
right right yeah no and so the the when
you combine this with
uh
they
the ability to to really create precise
models
uh but really really precise up to 90
precision without any additional data
that becomes already some powerful thing
and then you add data to it and you
really get to 95 98 precision which is
way more than what the the end user
needs
so
incredible
the journey for you ayala looking back
how do you summarize it for you because
it sounds like you've gone through a lot
it sounds like you're
you're celebrating the wins you're con
you're reflecting on on some of the the
things that that didn't go well
but it also sounds like you're you also
very much embody this an engineer
mentality right an algorithm algorithmic
person's mentality but how is this
experience for you i have to say the
biggest biggest i think growing uh you
know
it's a growing experience let's start
with that
um i lost you well i the biggest the
first growing experience was
losing some of my um
uh uh ego
so
at least being able to put it on the
side learning a lot of humility
um
you know justin is a simple example of
just a personal thing at exactly the
same time that i started the company
my
ex-girlfriend she moved our son to
germany so
it was a crushing moment for me and i
learned a lot of humility but it ended
up being very
you know
similar uh lesson to some things that i
experience in the company a lot of
humility there wow um
how does that humility translate to your
leadership style as the ceo of this
company
so it connects to the second thing i you
know i in 2020 last well now a year and
a half ago a
year and a little bit ago
we really uh said goodbye to pretty much
half the company and and hired really
a different house
and it's uh
you know the humility played a lot there
because i think it was the
the
first moment that one of our lead
investors from village global she she
said to me
and she said to me that uh hey you you
need to learn
to
not do everything
and so i learned not just not to do
everything but to recognize that really
all these people they know how to do
this so much better than me
you know everything i started with sales
which was the easy
thing but now it's also technology it's
product product was the biggest
revelation it was like this guy simone
uh
that we uh hired last year
amazing revolution it's like oh my god
that's how it should be done
and oh my god
and how long how and how long how many
years did the company run until simone
came and and provided sort of these this
aha moment about the products i mean
it's uh look last year it was really a
revolution we we got eagle in the sales
simone in product serena in marketing
and and now we we have
who's a
ceo he's he's the guy who actually built
companies and sold them
as founder ceo
and so you know i actually have people
who know what they're doing
and
that's like okay
i can just focus on
telling you guys roughly where to go but
you know what to do
i love it i love it and i love how it
connects to humility and too and and and
obviously i can't imagine it being easy
you know growing this baby and then
letting and and coming to an agreement
with half the team that it's not working
and and shifting things i mean i i can
only imagine how how difficult it is
especially given the the these
incredible things that you've done
before which i'm guessing turned out a
little bit different than the first half
of the journey of this company oh yeah i
mean the the last ha the last year has
been very very different very different
but but also it's not you know the the
previous guys were amazing they were
really really good at what they were
doing it's just that they were
not the right guys for the next stage
and it's
you know you bring the right people for
the stage and it's like the it's all of
a sudden the machine is like a
well-oiled like purring machine so
i love it i love it
i think that this journey is
i i you know i came in here wanting to
understand how to how can technology
solve parking but i'm leaving uh hearing
a remarkable journey uh from somebody
who who really you know embodies
humility and going and going through a
lot of these experiences and really and
i appreciate your openness and
vulnerability and be willing to speak to
about these things that i and i it was
just fascinating so thank you very very
much for your time and for your energy i
appreciate it a lot and and stay safe
and stay healthy and best of luck with
park nav thank you michael thank you for
the invitation great to meet you and
thanks for the time
wonderful thank you very much
[Music]
you